[Music]  holidays are a great time to riddle  americans with needless oppressive guilt  but the one that stands above the rest  head and shoulders is columbus day the  day where progressives indoctrinate your  children into believing columbus to be  satan incarnate  the usa to be his evil spawn and the  native americans to be pacifists we're  going to do a fireside chat with dennis  and uh a show with ben shapiro while in  los angeles  then back thursday for senator ted cruz  and philemon ann mackler so if you don't  see a lot of videos on this channel this  week  sorry another brush because there's a  lot to cover um  stay tuned and we'll be back to a  regular schedule next week and probably  some uploads here from los angeles  who knows i could get mugged it could be  like predator 2. there were also 25  american soldiers killed and 39 wounded  that's not genocide that's a one-sided  beatdown with old glory swinging the  hammer